This video is sponsored by Blue Apron.
In this video,
we're going to show you
how to make frozen hot chocolate,
a delicious summertime treat.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
To get started making this
delicious frozen hot chocolate,
you're probably going to need
a quick trip to the grocery store,
although none of the
ingredients are too crazy.
Here's the ingredients we'll need.
A bar of your favorite chocolate,
about 4 and 1/2 ounces,
some of your favorite hot cocoa mix,
regular white sugar,
some heavy whipping cream,
some milk,
and if you want to add a little bit
of extra sweetness to your dessert,
some whipped cream.
For today, here's the basic idea.
After whipping up a
few batches of our recipe,
we'll show you how to produce
the frozen hot chocolate
using a blender,
an ice cream machine,
a Ziploc bag full of ice,
or if you happen to have it,
some liquid nitrogen.
With all of our ingredients gathered,
let's make our first batch,
and throw it in
the ice cream machine.
Oh, no golden ticket.
Let's start by chopping up
our chocolate bar
into a bunch of
really small pieces.
[Music]
We want to melt all of our
chocolate in a double boiler.
That's when you take one pan,
and put it in another pan
that's full of water.
This prevents the pan
with the chocolate
from overheating and
burning your chocolate.
[Music]
Once you have a smooth creamy
consistency in your chocolate,
it's time to add the next ingredients.
2 tablespoons of hot cocoa powder,
and 1 and 1/2 tablespoons of sugar.
Stir that in until you have
a uniform consistency.
It won't be as smooth as it was before.
[Music]
Once the sugar and
hot cocoa are mixed in,
let's take it off the heat,
and add 1/2 cup
of heavy whipping cream.
[Music]
At this point,
I find that a whisk
works a little bit
better than a spatula.
[Music]
With the cream thoroughly mixed in,
now let's add one cup of milk.
[Music]
At this point, what we have
is a deliciously rich, extremely
chocolatey mixture that's
frankly a little too strong.
You wouldn't want to eat this plain,
except maybe a teaspoonful
about that size
because it's really really potent.
So what we actually
need to do now
is water it down with water.
Let's add 1 and 1/2 cups
of water into our mixture.
[Music]
With the water diluting it,
it tastes like an extremely delicious,
but room temperature hot chocolate.
So cool hot chocolate?
Cool chocolate?
Un-hot chocolate.
Let's make it cold.
Guys today's video
is sponsored by Blue Apron.
If you've never heard of them,
they are a food delivery company
that sends you all of the ingredients
and recipes you need
to make meals right in your home.
So many ingredients.
It's a really cool and convenient service
that's currently offering $50 off
of your first two weeks of food
for the first hundred people
to sign up with the link
down in the description.
One of my favorite
things about Blue Apron
is that for every box you get,
you can actually choose from
a collection of eight different recipes,
and you can select
the ones that you want.
I've got these three right here,
the sesame chicken noodles,
the steak and spicy butter,
and the blackened ginger pork burgers.
I am a huge fan of burgers,
so for today, I'm going
to be trying out with this one.
I love the little bottles.
They give you all the
sauces and stuff you need,
and they're just like
portioned out just the right size.
That's awesome.
[Music]
I love burgers.
Yeah.
Oh, these smells so good.
[Music]
Oh, this burger looks so good.
It's got sauce kind of
running down the sides of it,
but I'm okay with it.
[Music]
I don't have a ton of
experience with pork burgers,
but this is really good.
Like, that's another great thing is,
like it comes to these recipes,
expand your horizons.
Like learn new foods,
try them out,
and make them yourself, it's even cooler.
Guys, this is amazing.
Check the link in the description.
The first hundred people
to sign up will get $50 off
of their first
two weeks of food.
I highly recommend the burgers.
If you've never used one of
these ice cream machines before,
they're pretty simple.
This container goes in
the freezer for several hours
to lower the temperature quite a bit,
and then it just holds your liquid
while it spins in this machine.
Let's turn this on,
and pour in our mix.
[Music]
The ice cream machine
method is very simple,
but it does take some time,
and while that's running,
let's get our next batch started.
[Music]
This time, we're using the blender recipe,
and with the blender recipe,
we now need to add three
cups of ice into our blender,
and then pour our mixture over that.
We don't add any water because
the melting ice will dilute it enough.
[Music]
Once we blend up the ice,
this version of the frozen
hot chocolate is complete.
Cheers.
[Music]
The blender version gives
a much thinner consistency
than the other three methods.
So if you want a
version that you drink,
rather than eat with a spoon,
this is the way to go.
Oh it's so good.
There we go.
It has taken maybe 15-ish minutes,
and at this point,
our ice cream machine's
frozen hot chocolate
is just the right consistency.
[Music]
That's so good.
I can do this all day.
As you can see, the ice cream maker
does give us a little bit thicker
of a consistency than when
we make it in the blender.
For our next method, we're going
to be using something you may have done
if you've ever made ice cream at home.
That involves putting what
we're going to freeze in a Ziploc bag,
and putting that bag
inside of a bigger bag,
and filling the bigger
bag full of ice and salt.
I have here a 1 gallon freezer bag,
and a 2 gallon freezer bag.
So we've got our smaller one gallon bag.
We're going to pour
our mix into there
after adding the cream,
the milk, and the water.
That's about 3 cups of cool liquid.
So this is just room temperature.
We don't have to worry
about it melting the bag, or anything.
[Music]
Squeeze out as much of the air as we can.
Now, we just have a
bag full of liquid chocolate.
Now, we have our bag
of ice and a bunch of salt,
I'm using ice cream salt,
you can use other salt if you like.
It should all work just as well.
[Music]
Using about 8 cups of ice,
and now, we'll add about
one cup of our salt.
[Music]
Get the salt and ice nice
and mixed up together,
and now we take our smaller bag,
put it inside our larger bag.
Let's just make sure it's
nice and covered with our ice.
[Music]
I'm going to try and suck some
of the extra air out of this bag as well.
[Music]
That way all the ice should
pretty well stay in contact
with the bag inside.
And at this point, we just
need to start mixing it up.
We shake it,
and we squish it,
and scrunch it.
and just move it around
because we want all that salty ice
to be cooling down the mixture,
and we don't want it
to present to a solid piece.
We want it to freeze into a nice slush.
With this method, you can kind of
choose the consistency that you want.
If you want it to be thicker,
just keep it moving around in your
ice and salt for a little bit longer.
A little bit more of
a drinkable consistency,
just take it out sooner.
[Music]
After about 10 minutes of mixing
our hot chocolate around
inside that salty ice,
we have what is most definitely
not that same liquid consistency.
Now, let's rinse this off
so we don't accidentally end up
getting salt in our hot chocolate,
and scoop it out,
and see what it looks like.
Of course I do want
to rinse it very quickly
so I don't warm it back up.
[Music]
We have one more method to try,
and that is using liquid nitrogen.
Let's whip up one more batch,
and see how quickly we can make
frozen hot chocolate using that.
[Music]
There's our chocolatey base.
Now, let's add some
liquid nitrogen to it,
and see if we can
flash freeze this sucker.
[Music]
All of the liquid nitrogen
down inside our mixture
bubbling up is giving
it a really interesting
frothy texture on top.
[Music]
As you can see, all four
of these methods work great.
Some people are going
to have an ice cream maker,
some people won't.
I think most people
will have a blender,
but if not, Ziploc bags are
really easy to get your hands on,
and that method works just as well.
Of course, if you want
to get really fancy with it,
you can start adding things
like whipped cream and garnishes.
Figure out which method
works best for you,
and enjoy a cool, refreshing
chocolate treat this summer.
[Music]
Mine.
Guys, there's still
more for you to see.
That box up there will transport
you directly to our last video,
and you should go check it out.
The box down at the bottom
will show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and this bomb right here
will subscribe to our channel,
so you never miss another video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.